okay now this data
is the good stuff
james cromwell zeph from cochrane star
trek first contact all right so we have
a new lord of the rings show as a lord
of the rings fan myself i figure i would
dress my sunday best and give you my
thoughts on the first two episodes
anyway that's what aired i guess i'm
gonna start out with the nice the show
looks expensive
because that's that's what they've been
saying like this is the most expensive
show ever made always gives me a chuckle
in studios in hollywood it's like they
want to break records no matter what the
record is most expensive show ever made
great and if it doesn't work out that
would make you the dumbest studio ever
made cheers i mean i hope it works out i
hope it doesn't suck forever
by forever i mean i'll get there but it
does the show doesn't look like a tv
show in the sense of budget i mean it
definitely does look expensive is there
an argument to be made of the fact that
the lord of the rings trilogy wasn't the
most expensive film at the time so you
don't really need that to make a lord
that well well yes but you know credit
where credits do they wanted it to be
expensive and now it looks expensive all
right but the problem is after two
episodes going through these two
episodes that's two hours of
entertainment and i was just bored no
that does not mean slow burn slow burn
to me
was funny enough i feel like there's an
actual
textbook definition of slow burn if you
want to look it up i don't care but
slowburn to me
is when a movie a show a story in
general could be a book has the intrigue
of the audience it's an intriguing story
and the audience is going along with it
because there is a hook there
they just want to see what happens next
so the story is methodically taking its
time but it's doing that on purpose but
you feel that purpose you feel that
intent and you're going through the
story to hopefully some great payoff
boring is what i experienced in the
first two episodes the lord of the rings
rings of power will it pick up well it's
quite possible that's two hours where it
didn't two hours into lord of the rings
fellowship of the ring were you locked
in i was i actually just watched the
extended editions like yesterday so
maybe it's that fresh in my mind where
i'm like this does not feel the same and
you have to know that this this is not
peter jackson's lord of the rings world
i've heard stories about how the show
runners and amazon they like ghosted
peter jackson i don't know i wasn't
there i don't care that's not the point
of me saying this wait also it's been
way too long since my last tip but when
watching rings of power it's very clear
this is not peter jackson's tolkien
world it's not tied into the peter
jackson stories it's a completely
different thing galadriel is a new
galadriel not the kate blanchett
galadriel but younger elrond is a new
elron not hugo weaving but younger which
i feel is important for people to know
that because you know if you're going in
here like all right yeah it's those
characters but younger though
maybe they intended them to be the same
characters i'm just saying it's it's
better if you just don't see it that way
because at no point was i like that's
young galadriel for sure in fact
starting off they made her character i
was like what did you just do to her
character she's on the hunt with a few
elves under her command they're going to
where they want to find sauron then
there was this ice troll and they were
like eyes troll ice child just throws
this big old rocks flattens a couple of
them you're like whoa they've sounded
the alarm this is a big deal this is a
very oh galadriel just took care of it
in two seconds she does the thing where
she like slashes slashes and doesn't
even look at it took the entire
fellowship everything frodo almost died
because that spear would have skewered a
wild boar granted that was a cave troll
this is an ice troll guess they're
different yes ice trolls are the one
that someone can just clobber and take
down in two seconds without even barely
looking at it or even acknowledging
after the thing flattened a couple of
her friends moments like that i know
hollywood's like ooh how empowering it's
not though in terms of storytelling it
just it seems weak it just seems like
you're dealing with a character that's
unrelatable because any of us would be
sweating balls like oh my gosh i don't
want to take this thing on but i have to
but this character just kryptonians
herself through it it just takes it out
it's like oh okay
so i can't really
we can't bond through this experience
because i'm nothing like you taking on a
challenge while being afraid is the only
time someone can ever truly be brave she
had about the same look on her face that
i've had when i've sprayed raid onto
ants it's just kind of oh yeah
indifference so now that the show's made
you not root for galadriel what other
characters we got well you got new elf
characters you don't really care about
you have new halfling characters you
don't really care about of all the
characters elrond is clearly the best of
the characters in this show i was
intrigued with his scenes maybe i was i
just liked seeing kaza doom because he
went to moria and lord of the rings
online that was my mmo clocked in many
hours at home
at work
sorry former boss who probably watches
my videos i used to play it in the
projection booth
yeah why not see i was intrigued i've
heard they made elrond gay is there some
tension between him and another male
character
i suppose
i mean more than frodo and sam
no just in watching the show i was met
with that feeling of why didn't they do
something straight out of the
silmarillion i heard i haven't looked
into this there's been a lot of chatter
about this show that i haven't looked
into i was like i'll just have the
entertainment speak to me the way it
speaks to me but i've heard that there
were some rights limitations to what
they could use they couldn't use things
from the lord of the rings movie which
is fine
there are other stories out there there
are all these tolkien stories that they
could tell but they took some of the
stories from some vague appendices that
gives them the wiggle room to kind of go
their own way with it
which i just i don't think anyone was
asking for that i know that because when
the hobbit came out like through the
hobbits run in theaters the entire
trilogy people were like oh you're gonna
do the summer really next pete jackson
are you gonna you should granted wait a
minute
hold on this is the silmarillion
translating this into any series movie
or anything would be a pain in the ass
because sometimes the events are kind of
vague where it just kind of talks about
what happened rather than the specific
details but there are some great stories
some great tolkien history in here that
i really think fans would want to see
stories of morgoth of sauron i mean
granted the rings of power in the third
age is a chapter in here
um
it looks like the rings of power
in name
is trying to be a version of that but
not really it's just such a rich world
begging for translation i think a tv
show lends itself to something like the
silmarillion or at least a chapter of
the silmarillion because in my
experience part of the fun of something
like this is seeing the stories you know
translated on screen but with the rings
of power i don't really have that i
don't run into that feeling of oh these
are those stories that i've so wanted to
see on screen literally comes across as
people being like we can do tolkien
world better than tolkien did even at
the beginning of this show where it's
like more gothel was like oh sweet we're
gonna finally
we don't there's so much you can do with
morgoth there's so many people out there
lord of the rings fans you don't really
know who morgoth is you just why not
show morgoth how about the children of
heudrin i had watched that are you
kidding me i got that book from my
friend huge tolkien fan i was like hey
happy birthday new lord of the rings
book enjoyed he read it and he was like
that was a
downer no i'm thinking about it i'm like
awesome
why don't they do that i'd watch a show
revolving around that dude i guess the
point of this is the fact that we're
dealing with tolkien's world there are
literary scholars out there who dedicate
their entire careers and lives to the
world of middle earth to the world of
tolkien not only that but j.r.r tolkien
and his books his world have inspired
other authors to write their stories
without lord of the rings there would be
no game of thrones i just feel like a
world like that
deserves the respect that comes from a
proper translation at least make
galadriel the star of your show a
character i can root for
you know the little thing also side note
is that gandalf
is he he comes out of the sky in the
form of a comet lands has no memory
whatsoever i was like oh i know this
story the answer is simple reunite him
with his sword and he will remember that
he is the angel tyrial because this
is tyriel's arc in diablo 3. i've seen
the story before but i do ask whether or
not it's gandalf it's one of those
things where you ever have something or
situation maybe it's a movie but you
think to yourself hey if this twist
happens it would at least make it a
little cooler right i feel like the only
move that this show has to really pick
it up is a cool reveal that no one sees
coming in which i'd be like i guess that
wouldn't be gandalf that would be sauron
maybe i know we're supposed to think
that
eminem meth sauron is somehow sauron in
a world where sauron can take many forms
and he can take the form of someone
trusting what he took that form dude if
this dude came to me anywhere was like
hey you want these rings i'd be like
no no i don't but you have a good one
obviously you've you've done all the
rings that looks like a dude behind a
7-eleven selling broken counterfeit
otherwise shady merchandise saying no
it's legit trust me granted that dude
looks like the dude by the dude behind
the 7-eleven being like no his stuff is
[ __ ] you should buy my right so
you know i'm not saying one's better
than the other actually kind of looks
like
it is what it is hey looks like me
tomorrow morning whatever i mean could
be radagast the brown could be one of
the other wizards we haven't seen but
the implication seems to be oh no it's
totally gandalf though no one's called
him gandalf oral lauren no one's ever
actually addressed him and he hasn't
actually said his name be like it could
be a case of the show breaking the
fourth wall being like well what does
the audience consider trustworthy and a
trusting figure oh it would be gandalf i
don't know maybe my brain is doing that
thing where it's like okay here's how we
could make the show a little more
interesting because right now it's not
so lord of the rings the rings of power
does it have that which i loved about
lord of the rings not really it has far
too many characters they're spending the
currency that is that precious buildup
time you know that set up time with and
they're generally characters i don't
care about after two hours of
entertainment if a show doesn't have me
care about the characters well that's a
problem i will say this this does run
into that possibility much like how the
disney star wars movies made people like
me appreciate the prequels more this
lord of the rings show might actually
get people to appreciate the hobbit more
so hey keep an eye out for that as
pendulum swing am i going to do videos
in every episode i i don't i don't think
so
i just don't care too story time are you
ready before we leave the lord of the
rings movies
are actually
fundamental
among the orbit of my friends and i
young projectionists working at the
movie theater that i was the teaser
trailer for the lord of the rings
trilogy came out about a year before
fellowship of the ring did some
co-workers and i were near concessions
and we were talking about the trailer
and i said the phrase and i will quote
myself yeah magneto plays some wizard in
this movie and this concessionist
dropped everything he was doing he goes
some wizard no the wizard that
concessionist was named adam and we
remained friends to this day i was the
best man at his wedding if my friends
and i are planets in the solar system
the lord of the rings movies are
definitely the sun oh before we go
this was good but yeah as a lord of the
rings fan which the lord of the rings
means that much to me having me feel
indifferent throughout and to the end of
the first two episodes of your lord of
the rings show
not good so i don't know if i care to do
videos on every episode of this lord of
the rings show i'm enjoying house of the
dragon i'd rather do videos on something
i enjoy watching alright so lord of the
rings the rings of power have you seen
the first two episodes what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you